[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
whatsa Prof good day Walter hi Martin
are you doing good yes I'm doing fine
thank you yeah it's wonderful to be back
so let's first open with a word of
prayer and then we can discuss what
we're going to be doing
our heavenly father thank you that we
can be here again and discuss important
matters thank you for the opportunity we
ask that you please enlighten our minds
send the Holy Spirit to help us and also
protect us with your Holy Angels in
Jesus name amen
amen Martin there's so much talk about
the latter rain uh that is to be
expected the times we are living in
and uh perhaps we should look at some of
the movings of the spirit M and what
what we can expect and why and how can
we expect the outpouring of the latter
rain and is it something we can just ask
for can you maybe just briefly explain
what does l rain mean well the lat rain
is the the final outpouring of the
spirit comparable to what happened in
Pentecost so during Pentecost just on a
wider scale okay and uh you know people
are praying for the outpouring of the
Holy Spirit but is it that simple we
have to look at some of some of the
issues involved and also exactly what
does it mean is it this this uh
outpouring that everybody will receive
it and there will be a sudden change of
heart mhm will that happen or must the
preparation take place before the
outpouring of the holy spirit so these
are all kinds of questions you know many
many believe that uh if we fervently
pray for the outpouring of the spirit
then it'll
happen but uh are there conditions
attached so will it necessarily happen
without fulfilling the conditions that's
what we have to look at we have to
because if there are it's NE Neary that
we know what it is yes and what does the
spirit do it transforms the Heart Right
mhm so without uh the manifestation of a
transformed heart business as usual is
not going to cut it no so our backdrop
over here has the symbol of the dove the
moving of the spirit it has the people
subject to the rain as we see over here
so there are a lot of things to discuss
so let's jump into it Malachi
4:4 remember ye the law of Moses my
servant which I commanded unto him in
horb for all Israel with the statutes
and the judgments behold I will send you
Elijah the prophet before the coming of
the great and Dreadful day of the Lord
and he shall turn the heart of the
fathers to the children and the Heart of
of the children to their fathers lest I
come and smite the Earth with a curse so
Martin here is the promise of the Elijah
message not the literal Prophet but the
the message of the Prophet that will
come before the Dreadful day of the Lord
but it's interest interesting that it's
prefaced with this remember ye the law
of Moses my servant yeah yeah you cannot
separate the law
from the issues involved in the end
times from the message yes you cannot
you cannot separate the law from the
issues involved in the beginning true
from Adam and Eve all the way through
and we looked at it in the last one that
we did about how the Plan of Salvation
is to
unfold so the big problem is that people
want to separate the law of
Moses from the issues mhm and from the
message and from the message now what
did Elijah
do Elijah's message is basically that
he's not the
troubler of Israel yeah but ye pointing
to the King which is the type of the
kings of the world for you have forsaken
the Commandments of God yeah and you
followed
baale so that is that is the message a
turn to primitive godliness and
obedience to God's statutes that is the
Elijah
message and also an important part in
this Elijah message is to turn the
hearts of the children to their fathers
Les he come and smite them cor so
there's a there's a Reconciliation
message in that as well yes but there
must be a turning of
heart it can't be a super official Union
it's got to be a heart turning yeah and
remember Elijah confronted the prophets
of
Baal now it's very interesting that fire
came down from heaven mhm and consumed
the sacrifice of
Elijah but even though the prophets of
Baal had danced and cut themselves for
an entire day nothing happened the end
of the message is that the prophets of
baale were
destroyed yeah now we don't have to take
that through literally we can take it
through
typologically the message has to destroy
Bale Worship in US yes It Must Destroy
Bale Worship in us like you mentioned
yes and baale worship is a
counterfeit it's a counterfeit worship
and the Elijah message was very straight
you have forsaken the Commandments of
God
and Baal forsakes the Commandments of
God and puts
human laws in the place thereof yeah so
return back to the fathers and turn the
hearts of the
children James 5 tells us be patient
therefore Brethren unto the coming of
the Lord behold the husbandman Waites
for the precious fruit of the Earth and
has long patience for it until he
received the early and the latter rain
now is he talking about literal fruit
here M no no he's talking about
spiritual fruit that which Israel was
destitute of the Fig Tree had no fruit
it had presumptuous leaves but it had no
fruit
right and he's talking about the early
and the latter rain and who's the
husbandman Jesus what's he waiting
for for fruit yeah he's waiting for
fruit so without the fruit can you
expect the early and the latter rain no
no he's waiting for the fruit it's the
same that you shall know them by their
fruits if they just talk the talk but
don't have any fruits so if they don't
want the fruits then the house is left
to them desolate desolate so it's a very
serious message and a very
serious situation and and M and I
believe we're very close to these final
events yeah so if we are close to it
then it's very important that we start
getting the fruits okay do you think the
husbandman was patient until now oh yes
definitely has he been patient with his
church his Lan
church I think so has he given them
enough
rope yes
okay now this
spirit that we are expecting well the
spirit has always been working otherwise
there'd be no conversions and nobody
would accept Christ
right but this spirit is called the
spirit of
truth and the world cannot receive
it so if you have anything worldly in
you you cannot receive it such an
important statement that because it
seeth him not n knoweth him but ye know
for he dwelleth with you and shall be in
you so this Spirit of Truth and there
are the three definitions of Truth the
word is truth Jesus is the truth the law
is truth you take any one of those three
out then you have a partial truth and a
partial through truth just doesn't cut
it
right and he dwells with you but that's
not enough he has to be in
you now can the spirit of Truth abide
with the spirit of error no it's very
important right it's like what does
Christ have to do with B yeah they are
mutually
exclusive well John 15:26 and when the
comforter is come whom I will send unto
you from the father even the spirit of
Truth which proceeds from the
father he shall testify of me
me so the whole godhead is
involved in this
Mission and it has to testify of Christ
yeah now M what if you elevate the
spirit and make him the standard and the
norm and thereby reduce the role of
Jesus is there something wrong then yeah
because then it's turned on his head
okay so it has to testify of Christ so
if the Spirit doesn't Elevate
Christ then there's something wrong with
that Spirit you have to be very careful
right or John 16:13 how be it when he
the spirit of Truth is come he will
guide you into all
truth in other words the word will
become very precious Jesus will become
very precious yeah and the law will
become very precious yes all three of
them all three for he shall not speak of
himself but whatsoever he shall hear
that shall he speak and he will show you
things to come so the spirit not only
testifies of Christ it doesn't only
testify of the truth but it is also
prophetic tells you what is going to
come
yeah now if uh John Paul II
said that the holy spirit is the one
that we want to adore no that's false
then there's something wrong because
it's missing out that he shall testify
of Jesus right that's the main focus of
the spirit so don't shift the focus from
Jesus to the spirit and don't
underestimate the spirit because without
the spirit which was sent from the
father and from the
son you will not be able to stand in the
last days right true 1 John 4:6 we are
of God he that knoweth God heareth us
and he that is not of God heareth not us
hereby know we the spirit of truth and
the spirit of
error all right what did John testify of
what was his whole aim in life what was
he testifying well he was testifying
that Jesus is God that he is the Son of
God and that he is the creator yeah
so uh if the spirit doesn't want to hear
this then it is the spirit of error it's
as simple as that so can you you cannot
disconnect any of them right no
okay John 14: 26 I think everybody
should read chapter 14 every single day
yeah just to get to remind yourself yes
but the comforter it's such a it's it's
such a comforting word
which is the Holy Ghost whom the father
will send in my name he shall teach you
all things and bring all things to your
remembrance whatsoever I have said unto
you okay so that's a promise number one
you'll teach you all
things so this all things that Jesus all
the truth all truth will be so how much
can you leave out nothing nothing you
have to accept it all right can you cut
off the altar
Testament no especially don't need it no
no and bring all things to your
remembrance so with our feeble Minds
Fallen brains we need the Holy Spirit to
remind us of certain things to open
certain drawers in the brain right
yeah and whatsoever I have said unto you
well you just said did Jesus speak in
the Old Testament well didn't the
prophet say when when there wasn't even
a new
testament that prophecy didn't come from
man but came from God as the spirit
spoke through them as the Holy Spirit
spoke John 16 verse 7 nevertheless I
tell you the truth it is expedient for
you that I go away if I go not away the
comforter will not come unto you but if
I depart I will send him unto you now
why would he make a statement like that
why could the comforter not be there
when Jesus was still here on this Earth
why did he only come afterwards isn't
that an important question it's a very
important
question and it was a
promise and it was poured out in a great
measure at
Pentecost now when Jesus was on Earth he
was in confrontation with the forces of
evil right yes
and he overcame them in the Garden of
Gethsemane and he triumphed over them at
the cross yeah and then he had to go to
his father do not detain me he said to
Mary because I have not yet gone to the
father but I will go to the father and
then I'll come
back and he made this promise that the
comforter would only come after he had
departed when he was assured that his
sacrifice was sufficient and
accepted then he had the right to send
the spirit in measure wow that's amazing
that's true so it was the
confirmation of the coronation of Christ
so that his work that is done and he
said was finished was acceptable to the
father
yes and then when is
come what will be his job he will
reprove the world of sin and of
righteousness and of
judgment now when you think of the
Pentecostal
movement reproving the world of sin sin
is the transgression of the law but the
majority of the Pentecostal movement
says the law has been done away with so
they' have removed onethird of the
definition of truth
right
yeah and of righteousness where'd you
get your righteousness from from Christ
from
Christ and of judgment judgment means
there must be a standard of judgment
what is the standard of judgment the law
the law so he'll reprove the world of
the transgression of the law and that is
the standard of judgment and you better
accept the righteousness of Christ or
else you're not going to have a leg to
stand on correct then that law is going
to condemn you all right of sin because
they believe not on me sure why did
christ have to die we discussed it in
the last one and sin is the
transgression of the law but rejecting
Christ is rejecting the law exactly it's
it cannot be severed because it's his
character you can't do that of
righteousness because I go to my father
and you see me no more so there you have
the promise of the acceptance of the
sacrifice yeah of righteousness is it
acceptable My Sacrifice to justify
Humanity through my righteousness well
you will see it when I go to my father
and you see me no more then the spirit
will be poured out does that begin to
make sense yeah definitely
okay of judgment because the prince of
this world is judged so when the
outpouring of the Holy Spirit takes
place it means that Christ has taken
back the keys he is again the one who
has redeemed humanity and this world and
the prince of this world who is Satan is
judged yeah so the outpouring of the
spirit is the confirmation of the
Victory and the coronation of Christ
amazing it's interesting H
wow and when doesn't often read these
verses like this you just glance over
them you don't you don't look at why is
the wording so strange and it gives you
an whole picture of how the Plan of
Salvation did not just end at the cross
no it went forth into heaven yes where
he is now mediating on our behalf we
have an
advocate in
heaven the comforter is called the
Spirit of Truth this comes from the
Desire of Ages everybody should read
that book oh
definitely his work is to Define and
maintain the truth he first dwells in
the heart as the spirit of Truth and
thus becomes the
comforter so when you live in the world
that we are living in now I think it's
quite necessarily that we have a
comforter don't you think that's you go
crazy in this world you will but
the another thing that I see here is if
you have the spirit of truth then he
becomes the comforter so if you don't
have the spirit of truth yes if you
think you have the spirit but you don't
keep the to what the definition of Truth
is which is the law and all of that you
cannot be comforted you cannot be
comforted there is comfort and peace in
the truth but no real peace or Comfort
can be found in falsehood it is through
false the theories and
traditions that Satan gains his power
over the Mind by directing men to false
standards he misshapes the character
through the scriptures the Holy Spirit
speaks to the mind and impresses truth
upon the heart and this is very very
important it is through the word which
is the definition of truth that God
speaks to you uh it doesn't say through
your feelings
that's so important you come out of the
charismatic movement it is an emotional
event exactly you're waiting you you
believe you don't haven't received the
spirit until there's an emotion yes thus
he exposes error and expels it from the
soul it is by the spirit of Truth
working through the word of God that
Christ subdues his chosen people to
himself so you negate the word and
elevate the experience and you are in
very dangerous
ground in describing to his disciples
the office work of the Holy Spirit Jesus
sought to inspire them with a joy and
hope that inspired his own heart he
rejoiced because of the Abundant help he
had provided for his church the Holy
Spirit was the highest of all gifts that
he could solicit from his father for the
exaltation of his people people the
spirit was to be given as a regenerating
agent and without this the sacrifice of
Christ would have been of no
avail so the spirit regenerates inside
of you it has to work in the heart yes
there must be a decided change it's not
a manifestation of you having received
power and the power is is evidence that
you are accepted by God no
it actually should humble
you and not Elevate you that's for sure
it must show you because then you
realize how low you are actually yes
because of sin so the power of evil had
been strengthening for centuries and the
submission of men to this satanic
captivity was
amazing sin could be resisted and
overcome only through the mighty agency
of the the third person of the godhead
who would come with no modified energy
but in the fullness of divine
power I think some people might be upset
by that statement but that is how it is
that's how it's written and even if you
compare this to what we've just read in
John there's there's no argument there's
no argument it's one and the same even
go there it is the spirit that makes
effectual what has been brought out by
the world's Redeemer it is by the spirit
that the Heart Is Made pure so M what is
the work of the spirit to transform you
yeah not to manifest to other that you
suddenly have become a super beinging no
and to get you away from worldliness yes
through the spirit the believer becomes
a partaker of the divine nature Christ
has given his Spirit as a divine power
to overcome all hereditary and cult
iated Tendencies to evil and to impress
his own character upon his church so the
work of the holy spirit is
transformation of character yeah that's
the
work and if it doesn't do this then it
is a spous spirit I might just give a
small advertisement I think people can
go and watch your series total
transformation also again
okay so the first disciples went forth
preaching the word they revealed Christ
in their lives and the Lord worked with
them confirming the word with signs
following according to Mark 16:20 these
disciples prepared themselves for their
work before the day of Pentecost they
met together and put away all
differences they were of one Accord
whoa all differences all differences
okay what was the condition for the
outpouring of the spirit that was the
condition they must be of one
mind and they must be of one Accord
Martin can you pray for the outpouring
of the Holy Spirit without fulfilling
this condition
no is it being done in the
world yes there are everywhere people
are praying but not adhering to what is
necessary okay so they have they have
their ideas and the others have other
ideas and they get all kinds of
labels but they haven't put aside all
differences
no they believed Christ's promise that
the blessing would be given and they
prayed in faith they did not ask for a
blessing for themselves merely they were
waited with the burden for the Salvation
of
souls it's a very important thing
you know is is this outpouring a
manifestation selfishly that you want to
show that you are accepted or is it that
you want to reach Souls see
so sometimes we'll say that we wish
Jesus would come but that's actually a
selfish statement yeah I want him to
come I want to but I want to save I want
to see people saved as well that's our
burden has to be
Souls the gospel was to be carried to
the uttermost parts of the earth and
they claimed the endowment of power that
Christ had promised then it was that the
Holy Spirit was poured out and thousands
were converted in a day so M it's very
important to be of one
Accord so just a question is Jesus
waiting to come for the church first to
become one-
minded mtin do you think the church will
ever become one- minded no I don't think
so either but are there people within
the church that through studying and
prayer are becoming one- minded yes H so
is he working on souls for sure and will
there then be a shaking yes we will
still come to that okay so who's
actually in control is it God or is it
humanity is God waiting for his church
or is the church Waiting for God to
manifest his people that's that's the
difference in approach it's a very good
analogy that you just gave I I I love
that God is still in control so he's not
waiting for the church no it is
presumption to think that God is
subjected to us no the time will come
when he says Ready or Not the End time
events are taking place and then by what
you've just has explained his church the
ones that are waiting will be ready they
will be ready and they will be of one
Accord yeah so praying for the
outpouring of the spirit is an important
thing but meeting the
conditions is a little bit difficult is
absolute
Paramount so the answer may come with
sudden velocity and overpowering might
it might be delayed for days and weeks
maybe years maybe decades maybe a
century but God knows how and when to
answer our prayer it is our part of the
work to put ourselves in connection with
the Divine Channel God is responsible
for his part of the work he is faithful
who has promised the great and important
matter with us is to be of one heart and
mind putting aside all Envy malice and
as humble supplicant to watch and wait
Jesus our representative and head is
ready to do for us what he did for the
praying watching ones in the day of
Pentecost so in whose hand lies the
power in God in Jesus's hands okay so he
is not
impotent waiting for the church to
finally let him in actually his Mercy is
letting the church still struggle to get
to this portion yes what is our job
Martin to be of one heart and mind and
putting aside all Envy
malice and to watch and to
wait it's a tough call because that goes
against your nature and Satan is also in
the mix here so he's really trying to
keep us not to have this Accord okay all
right let's have a look at the example
of the
reformers uh this is the heading that we
find withdrawal of the faithful after a
long and severe conflict the faithful
few decided to dissolve all Union with
the apostate church if she still refused
to ref free herself from falsehood and
idolatry so that's what they did the
reformers yes Luther no matter who they
were Calvin Knox whatever their names
were Ridley
[Music]
cranman all of them they had to separate
from the churches
why because the church refused to free
herself from falsehood and
idolatry has the Roman Catholic Church
changed one iot of its doctrines since
that time no not one so with the same
Criterium apply 100% yes so what does
that do to ecumenism sorry goodbye not
at all there's no way there's no way
because truth and error cannot be bad
fellows no all right so what did they do
they saw that separation was an absolute
necessity if they would obey the word of
God and it hasn't changed nothing has
changed so it's still an absolute
necessity they dared not tolerate errors
fatal to their own souls and set an
example which would imperil the faith of
their children and children's children
so when the hearts of the children are
turned to the fathers that means you
must accept that error is still error
and you cannot be associated with it and
maybe just to make it clear this is to
separate from those systems those false
systems not the false errors of people
inside the system correct you need to
help those people to see the
truth all right to secure peace and
unity they were ready to make any
concession consistent with Fidelity to
God but they felt that even peace would
be too dearly purchased at the sacrifice
of principle if Unity could be secured
only by the compromise of Truth and
righteousness then let there be
difference and even
War that's pretty clear and that makes
sense and was there difference oh yes
and was there war huge okay well would
it be for the church and the world if
the principles that actuated those stead
fought Souls were revived in the heart
hearts of God's professed
people well Martin that puts a very
straight
challenge to the Church of today the
God's professed people yes and it is
diametrically opposed to some people of
High standing who would rather seek
compromise and bury doctrinal
differences for the sake of Peace
exactly we must get away from being
acceptable in the world's eyes and get
and stand for what the truth is now Mar
when it came to
1844 and the proclamation of the first
Angel's
message the time of his judgment has
come worship Him made and preaching the
Everlasting gospel which go back to the
roots go back to the Bible and what does
the bible teach and not tradition
when it came to the second Angel's
message Babylon has fallen has
fallen were the people compelled to also
separate from the churches that refused
to accept the standard exactly the same
happened again as happened in the reform
reformers time and the third Angel's
message do not accept the mark of the
beast do not accept a false system of
Standards yeah in the place of the real
and that's been running since then yes
the the first Angel and second Angel
hasn't stopped they still preaching it's
still going and the third Angel is all
is has to be preached
correct so many who profess to be
looking for the speeding coming of
Christ are becoming conformed to this
world and seek more earnestly the
Applause of those around them than the
approbation of God they want to be on a
list
so that they are accepted by the world
so this list that says Christian yes
even though the Mormons and all
domination denominations that don't even
qualify as Christian is actually on it
now we have to compromise to be on the
list I don't think it's uh what we
should do they are called and formal
like the nominal churches from which
they but a short time since
separated the words addressed to the Lan
Church describe their present condition
perfectly they are neither cold nor H
but
lukewarm and unless they heed the
counsel of the faithful and true witness
and zealously repent and obtain gold
refined and the fire that's
character white rment that's the
righteousness of Christ and I solve so
that you can understand the scriptures
he will spew them out of his mouth it's
pretty straight yeah and it's biblical
and that's the condition so we cannot
expect the latter rain and the
outpouring until the conditions have
been
met this comes from the story of
redemption the Apostle Paul declares
that all that live Godly in Christ Jesus
shall suffer persecution they will be
called terrorists it's actually a
promise yes why is it then that
persecution seems in a great degree to
Slumber the only reason is that the
church has conformed to the world's
standard and therefore awakens no
opposition he what do you think about
that I think it's very clear
straightforward so the religion current
in our day is not of the pure and holy
character which marked the Christian
faith in the days of Christ and his
Apostles it is only because of the
spirit of compromise with sin because
the great truths of the word of God are
so indifferently regarded because there
is so little vital godliness in the
church that Christianity is apparently
so popular with the world let there be a
Revival of the faith and power of the
early church and the spirit of
persecution will be revived and the
fires of persecution will be
rekindled Martin do you think the church
is ready for the outpouring of the Holy
Spirit no there must come a shaking
right there must come a shaking and I
think a lot of introspection in all of
our hearts all of us every single one of
us nobody is immune from this
so what does it mean unity and the
spirit of
Prophecy now we are throwing a spanner
in the works here again which is part of
our
job can't have it otherwise can't have
it
now some who are not willing to receive
the light but who prefer to walk in ways
of their own choosing will search the
testimonies to find something in them to
encourage the spirit of unbelief and
Disobedience thus a spirit of disunion
will be brought in we're supposed to
have Union right yes so what will bring
disunion when you start neglecting the
testimonies yes and and giving them a
new format maybe saying well maybe she
didn't have the same Authority or maybe
it's just for that time or maybe for
that time yes thus the spirit of
disunion will be brought in for the
spirit which leads them to criticize the
testimonies will also lead them to watch
their Brethren to find in them something
to
condemn Satan is constantly pressing in
the spus to lead away from the truth the
very last deception of Satan will be to
make of none effect the testimony of the
spirit of God that doesn't mean you're
going to take it away you're just going
to make it of non effect non effect it's
not important anymore no it was for her
day for her day it was for her time
didn't have the same
Authority where there is no vision the
people
perish Satan will work
ingeniously in different ways and
through different agencies to unsettle
the confidence of God's Remnant people
in the true
testimony
Martin is the spirit of Prophecy part of
the Union that is to be attained
absolutely you agree you believe
absolutely you believe that I've had a I
did a sermon once on it where I
said if you want unity in the church
let's get Unity around the spirit of
Prophecy did it go well no it didn't go
well all
right there will be a hatred kindled
against the testimonies which is
satanic the workings of Satan will be to
unsettle the faith of the churches in
them for this reason Satan cannot have a
clear a track to bring in his deceptions
and bind up souls in his delusions if
the warnings and reproofs and counsels
of the spirit of God are
heeded all right let me ask the question
are there people in the church that are
studying the spirit of Prophecy and want
to conform their lives to the standards
that are there propagated yes for sure
are there people that are dead against
it yeah yes do you see it at every
potluck yes is there a war a war every
time right every single time now who's
the war against is it is it against you
personally or is it against the
principal you see that's the problem
people should realize it's not against
the person it's against the message it's
against the message and just think of it
if you there's unity in some of the
things of this Spirit of Prophecy yes
but not in all not all but that you have
to have it in all it's just like the
Bible and the Bible can you say I accept
this but I don't accept that no well if
the Pope says we have to throw out
Doctrine otherwise we will never get
Unity let's rather concentrate on that
which we agree on and forget that which
we disagree on or as one of them who's
no longer alive said God will sort out
all our differences when we get upstairs
I'm sorry the differences have to be
sorted out now now Unity like we've just
read so M would you agree that the holy
spirit is there to transform our
characters
absolutely so when Psalms
51:7 says Purge me with hop and I shall
be clean wash me and I shall be whiter
than
snow make me to hear joy and gladness
that the bones which thou Hast broken
May Rejoice hide thy face from my sins
and blot out all mine
iniquities create in me a clean heart oh
God and renew a right Spirit Within Me
does this sound like the work of the
Holy Spirit
yes cast me not away from thy presence
and take not thy Holy Spirit from me
that's a plead all right they didn't
have the power of Pentecost but the
spirit was leading oh for sure yeah
restore unto me the joy of thyself
salvation uphold me with thy free spirit
then will I teach transgressors thy way
and sinners shall be converted unto the
transgression of what Martin the law
can't get away from it you can't get
away and so can you be converted unto
God without this no no no because as
soon as you understand the
issue with horror you will see but my
children are not living up to this
standard yeah or my wife or my husband
is not living up to this standard or the
members of my church or my friends are
not living up to this standard I better
tell them and then you are very favored
yes then you will be very
popular all right Martin so what should
our attitude be towards
unbelievers now it gets complicated
because there's a method of Christ then
there's a method of
man Matthew 9:36 but when he saw the
multitude he was moved with compassion
on them because they had fainted and
were scattered abroad as sheep having no
Shepherd so what must our attitude be to
those who do not understand or do not
live up to the truth you have to have
compassion and and not get excited okay
so you can have a condemning spirit you
could have a compassionate spirit so
let's ask God to give us a compassionate
spirit so that the Holy Spirit can
actually start working I I can just
maybe add on if you pray and ask God to
give you a compassionate Spirit he's not
going to take away the the things that
makes you a little bit edgy no you're
actually probably going to get some more
of it you're probably going to get more
Edy that's how you get taught Mark 2:17
you we always ask the question why me
Lord It's a wrong question why not me
Lord when Jesus heard it he said unto
them they that are whole have no need of
a physici but they that are sick I came
not to call the righteous but Sinners to
repentance all right so do we become
like the Pharisees and condemn everybody
that is Off the Mark or are we moved
with compassion and call them that are
off the mark to repentance that's our
duty that's how we that's exactly how it
should be done but it's also important
to
realize he came to call the righteous
not the righteous but Sinners and it
doesn't stop there no to repentance if
you leave that repentance out then then
you have a half a Gospel Matthew 9:13
but go ye and Lear what that means I
will have mercy and not sacrifice so I
don't want a
ritual no I don't have a a Works based
religion I want to see Mercy because the
sacrifice is there only as a symbol for
the mercy yeah so it's again a heart
thing for I'm not come to call the
righteous but Sinners to
repentance it's fascinating that some of
the new translation leave that out why
do they want to half a gospel yeah the
PE and it makes it easy because
repentance is not an easy thing but just
being called that's okay that's fine I'm
fine like I am all right now the work of
Christ was to find in the
Bible if that was the work of Christ and
we are to be Christ like mustn't become
our work too yeah all right so when you
go to Isaiah chapter 61 where the
mission of the Messiah is proclaimed it
says the spirit of the Lord God is upon
me because the Lord has anointed me to
preach Good Tidings unto the
meek he has sent me to bind up the
Brokenhearted to Proclaim Liberty to the
captives and the opening of the prison
to them that are
bound does this imply a war oh
definitely because it's right against
what Satan wants okay so Humanity is
brokenhearted they have been taken
captive by the devil through his
lies and they are actually imprison yeah
they need to be set free that's a prison
of sin to proclaim the acceptable year
of the Lord and the day of Vengeance of
our God to comfort all that mourn to
appoint unto them that mourn in Zion to
give unto them beautyful
ashes oil of joy for Mourning
the Garment of Praise for the spirit of
heaviness that they might be called
Trees of Righteousness the planting of
the Lord that he might be glorified it's
a it's actually a marvelous Mission it's
beautiful is it our mission yes every
single person that's our mission right
yeah so in Luke you find the repetition
of this so the New Testament confirms
that this is the mission of the Messiah
yeah not what they expected right no
it's exact opposite of what they
expected exact opposite all right and
when Jesus read it we don't have to read
it again because it's the same yeah he
ends it here by saying and he began to
say unto them this
day is this scripture fulfilled in your
ears wow what year was that just 27 ad
27 ad he sat in this church he' just
come out of the Wilderness experience
and he says this
day is this scripture fulfilled in your
ears were they happy with that statement
no because he was applying the mission
of the Messiah to himself yes but they
misconstrued the mission in the first
place it sounds a bit familiar actually
it's absolutely
amazing so when Christ gave his
disciples the promise of the spirit he
was nearing the close of his Earthly
Ministry he was standing in the shadow
of the cross with a full realization of
the load of guilt that was to rest upon
him as the sin
Bearer before offering himself as a
sacrificial victim he instructed his
disciples regarding a most essential and
complete gift which he was to bestow
upon his followers the gift that would
bring within the there reach the
boundless resources of his grace so this
was the power that was to change the
whole world it was the Divide of History
M you know you divided into before
Christ and after Christ yeah they don't
even like that so they now make it
before Common Era and after Common Era
which is absolute ridiculous idiocy and
patheticness doesn't make sense even I
refuse to use that terminology
because they don't want to acknowledge
that he is the Divide of History
yeah I will pray the father he said and
he shall give you another comforter that
he may abide with you
forever even the spirit of Truth whom
the world cannot receive because it
seeth him not neither knoweth him but ye
know him for he dwelleth with you and
shall be in you the Savior was pointing
forward to the time when the Holy Spirit
should come to do a mighty work
as his
representative the evil that had been
accumulating for centuries was to be
resisted by the divine power of the holy
spirit so M how can you become right
with God you have to allow the spirit to
change you is there any power within you
that can do it no because and that's the
beautiful
part he the holy spirit will lead you to
Christ and his righteousness what is the
only way when you think about these
things and you think of the Pentecostal
movement is this what is happening there
or is there something else happening
there no it's something totally
different but if you take the ministry
of Ben hin it's the whole time this
power religion power power treading on
serpents giving you might instead of
humbling you down to the ground right so
the Holy Spirit represents worldly
kingdoms under the symbol of fierce
beasts of
prey but Christ is the Lamb of God which
taketh away the sins of the world John
1:29 in his plan of government there is
no employment of Brute Force to compel
the
conscience oh wow we're not going to set
up the kingdom by
force the Jews look for the king om of
God to be established in the same way as
the kingdoms of the world to promote
righteousness they resorted to external
measures they devised methods and plans
but Christ implants a
principle by implanting truth and
righteousness he cter works error and
sin so that's why it's so important that
church and state cannot come together no
because why would the church need the
state to enforce something not to
implant a principle for sure not you
cannot implant a principle you cannot
force a principle they've tried how many
times communism tried it they wanted to
enforce to teach you how to think but
that's that principle cannot be
sustainable now Martin we talk in this
day and age of
postmodernism we're living in the
postmodern age and you know you always
think what what exactly does that mean
post Modern Age now we were up
until the 60s we were in what was called
The Age of
Reason started by the thinkers such as
deart and Vol and the French
Revolution and reason took the place of
Revelation so now you had a generation
that was based on
reason and it flour and you had
scientific progress and all of these
things but an emptiness developed in the
soul yes there was a divide being
captured yes and then you came to the
postmodern era which says does this Age
of Reason really Supply what he's
lacking in the soul no and then you get
to Generation X
mhm gen Generation X and you wonder
where do all these terms come from and
what do they
mean Generation X is from the 60s from
round about 1962 to
the80s that
generation that grew
up in the most horrendous
circumstances where the meaning of life
seemed to escape
them and the drug world was very
prevalent and so this generation which
found in this Age of
Reason nothing for themselves most of
them grew up living with their parents
because they couldn't afford places of
themselves they didn't get jobs they
were they were destitute they were like
like a generation
discarded and if you look at their
statistics they have the highest divorce
rate of all Generations in the history
of
humanity they are a a trampled
generation and we're living with them
because those are the adults of our day
now and actually that generation gave
let's say birth to the reason why people
don't want to marry even okay and this
generation Longs for something
better than what the previous generation
promised and offered this great
Prosperity that never materialized
because they can't even afford a house
they constantly changing relationships
most of them were dependent upon drugs
and they're looking for some meaning and
now Christianity is going to be
reinvented and give them some
meaning Z there's this this this hunger
for something
else and they're going to reinvent
Christianity as we speak about
constantly there's going to be this
pendulum shift yes
yes and thousands upon thousands upon
disillusioned people might just grab
hold of it yeah and if they don't meet
the
conditions they're going to go to
petion how important is it that we put
this in the right perspective
it's
Paramount because like you just
mentioned a lot of people would out of
desperation just want to cling onto it
cling onto something but there won't be
a heart transformation no and so you
have these Mega TV personalities all of
a sudden embracing norms and standards
that have been buried by an Age of
Reason yeah in this postmodern
Generation X society that we are living
in we're living in a very fascinating
time with a very vulnerable Humanity
yeah that's true and a very
disillusioned Humanity
they don't know which way is there any
trust left in government for example
nobody trusts government right is there
any trust in in the fraternities even in
the scientific world with its
disconcordant notes you see the problem
is some people cling to it even though
they know it can't even be trusted
anymore correct because they don't have
anything else to cling on where that's
where we have to come in and get them to
that's why it's so important that we
understand understand the mission of the
Holy Spirit the grace of God takes men
as they are and works as an educator
using every principle on which an
all-sided education depends the steady
influence of the grace of God trains the
soul after Christ's
method and every Fierce passion every
defective tray of character is worked
upon the molding influence of the spirit
of Christ so it's his character
until the man has a new Motive Power and
becomes filled with the holy spirit of
God after the likeness of the Divine
similitude if there is not this
transformation this Total
Transformation then it is a spous
transformation it's a grabbing at straws
yeah Christ came to bring Salvation
within the reach of all upon the cross
of Calvary he paid the infinite
Redemption price for a lost
World his self-denial and self-sacrifice
his unselfish labor his humiliation
above all the offering up of his life
testifies to the depth of his love for
fallen man it was to seek and save the
lost that he came to Earth his mission
was to sinners sinners of every grade of
every tongue and Nation he paid the
price for All to Ransom them and bring
them into Union and sympathy with
himself the most
earing the most sinful were not passed
by his labors were especially for those
who most needed the Salvation he came to
bring the greater their need of Reform
the deeper was his interest the greater
his sympathy and Mild
measures soft answers pleasant words are
much more fitted to reform and save than
severity and harshness could we apply
that in our churches wouldn't that be
nice I can apply that in my life as
well I think if we start implementing
this we can get forward to start asking
for the holy spirit in the latter rain a
little too much unkindness may Place
persons beyond your reach while a
conciliatory Spirit would would be the
means of binding them to you and you
might then establish them in the right
way you should be actuated by a
forgiving Spirit also and give you
credit to every good purpose and action
of those around you Martin with all the
accusations that are flying around are
we displaying this character the spirit
no no we have to look at ourselves don't
we ourselves but if I just look think of
what's been happening and we're talking
about our church now in you know I think
there's a little bit of that lacking at
this stage God has done his part of the
work for the Salvation of men and now he
calls for the cooperation of the
church there are the blood of Christ the
word of Truth the Holy Spirit on one
hand and there are the perishing Souls
on the other every follower of Christ
has a part to act to bring men to accept
the blessings Heaven has
provided let us closely examine
ourselves and see if we have done this
work let us question our motives and
every action of our lives are there not
many unpleasant pictures hanging in
memory
Halls so Martin are we so great because
we know the truth no if we don't are
there unpleasant pictures in our picture
gallery of Our Lives M and if you look
at them
perhaps we shouldn't concentrate so much
on that but concentrate on what Christ
has done yeah that's
true often have you needed the
Forgiveness of Jesus so shouldn't you be
of a forgiving Spirit yourself in the
prayer that Jesus gave to the disciples
father forgive us as we forgive those
who've trespassed against us so if you
don't forgive those people you're asking
ask the father not to forgive you
correct you have been constantly
dependent upon his compassion and love
yet have you not failed to manifest
towards others the spirit which Christ
has exercised towards
you have you felt a burden for the one
whom you saw venturing into forbidden
paths have you kindly admonished him
have you wept for him and prayed with
him and for him have you shown by words
of tenderness and kindly acts that you
love him and desire to save him right
now we fulfilling the condition for the
outpouring of the
spirit no I don't think so his great
Heart of Love was stirred to its depth
for the ones whose condition was most
hopeless and who most needed his
transforming Grace but there has been
among us as a people a lack of deep
Earnest Soul's touching sympathy and
love for the tempted and the earing many
have manifested great coldness and
sinful neglect represented by Christ as
passing by on the other side keeping as
far as possible from those who most need
help the newly converted Soul often has
Fierce conflicts with established habits
or some special form of Temptation and
being overcome by some master passion or
tendency is guilty
of indiscretion or actual wrong it is
then that energy tacked and wisdom are
required of his Brethren that he may be
restored to spiritual
health Brethren if a man be overtaken in
a fault ye which are spiritual restore
such a one in a spirit of meekness
considering thyself lest thou also be
tempted or as Roman says we then that
are strong ought to Bear the infirmities
of of the weak and not to please
ourselves so M the spirit's
work is not what people expect they want
Power yeah and but they need humility
and meekness and soft softs
spokenness we don't have to read
everything let's just read the
highlighted
portions let the tenderness and mercy
that Jesus has revealed in his own
precious life be an example to us of the
manner in which we should treat our
fellow beings especially those who are
our brethren in Christ never lose an
opportunity to say a word to encourage
and Inspire
hope I wish we could all practice that
well let's make it a challenge it's so
much nicer to condemn someone oh but
that's because we don't have the the the
spirit of truth that's convicting us so
let's make it a challenge let see if we
can from now on try this all right now
let's can I throw another spanner in the
work of
course we've got a whole toolbox full of
it so so we might as well use the
spanners let's irritate everybody while
we're busy
right does our lifestyle play a role for
sure it's it's one of those portions
that everything is fine but this one
we'll look after it later so God will
give his people ability and TCT to
prepare wholesome food without these
things in other words these things are
all the things that you shouldn't
actually have to have on your
table let our people discard all UNH
wholesome recipes let them learn how to
live healthfully teaching to others what
they have learned let them impart this
knowledge as they would Bible
instruction
that's quite quite a heavy you see now
the some let me just put it there some
people must now REM remember what we've
just said before of the meekness and
humility and so don't attack now just be
meek and listen Okay let them teach the
people to preserve the health and
increase the strength by avoiding the
large amount of cooking that has filled
the world with chronic
invalids by precept and example make it
plain now listen to this Martin that the
food which God gave adam in his sinless
state is the best for man's use as he
seeks to regain that sinless
state so who's working in you to help
you to regain a better State the holy
spirit is working in you but there's
requirements to it's it's with the rest
of the requirements we've just read this
is part of that all right so
mtin
diet and the narrow road to attain to
the character of
Christ are connected
right cannot s so if you want
Unity do we have to be of one Accord as
far as this is concerned as well we have
to does this form part of the Spirit of
Prophecy and of the bible message so
what is on your
plate can it affect what's in the heart
yes for sure all right Martin so we are
to rebuke evil in the world but we may
not judge the soul and there's a very
clear distinction between the
two Leviticus 19:17 Thou shalt not hate
thy brother in thine
heart Thou shalt in any wise rebuke Thy
Neighbor and not suffer sin upon him you
may not hate him but you may rebuke him
so it says here you cannot judge but you
can't rebuke yes you actually you should
reuke yeah Ecclesiastes 7 ver 5 it is
better to hear the rebuke of the wise
than for a man to hear the song of
fools so are you supposed to be rebuking
people but with obviously the love that
we've just
everything we spoken about some people
love the
rebuking but they fail to see the
portion that we just
discussed well second Timothy 4:2 preach
the word be instant in season out of
season reprove rebuke exort with all
longsuffering and Doctrine can you throw
Doctrine out the window no no it's your
standard for your rebuke and reproof of
course but but the Pope says we must
throw Doctrine out the window yeah
because that makes it a nice comfy uh
ecumenical Gathering all right now this
is this is this is the tricky part
you're supposed to do all these
things but you're not supposed to
neglect the way in which it's supposed
to be done exactly so once you read
these you should read the way in which
you should do it as well that we've just
mentioned in the previous section now I
found this statement in Council for the
church very
fascinating Christ humbled himself to
stand at the head of humanity to meet
The Temptations and endure the trials
that Humanity must meet and
endure he must know what Humanity has to
meet from the Fallen foe that he might
know how to sucker those who are
tempted and Christ has been made our
judge the father is not the
judge that's a very interesting
statement because Jesus confirms it he
says all judgment has been given unto me
right yeah so the father is not the
judge the angels are not he took
Humanity upon himself and in this world
lived the perfect life is to judge us
he's the one yeah he who took the
humanity yeah he only can be our judge
will you remember this
Brethren will you remember it ministers
will you remember it fathers and mothers
Christ took you Humanity that he might
be our judge no one of you has been
appointed to be a judge of
others so I may say to
you one what you are doing is not
healthful it's very destructive it's
actually your duty it wouldn't it be
better if we did it this way or that way
yeah or I could say you know if you
continue like that you're going to go to
hell what's the difference between the
two the one is the spirit of Truth is
missing and it's judgment yeah you've
already judged exactly that that's
already giving a judgment correct so no
one of you has been appointed to judge
others you may judge the actions and
then bring the re rebuke but you may not
judge the outcome that's not your job
well if you want to judge the action the
rebuke part it's just it has to be
adjusted on how you bring it over okay
it is all that you can do to discipline
yourselves in the Name of Christ I
entreat you to heed the injunction that
he gives you never to place yourselves
on the Judgment seat from day to day
this message has been sounded in my ears
come down from the Judgment seat come
down in
humility and
Martin this is what we're supposed to do
yeah this is what the spirit is supposed
to lead us to
well I can I was I would just want to
say here as well that it's there's a
flip side also if somebody comes to you
with a very loving rebuke you should
also let the spirit of Truth work in you
and take it with a good heart and not
flare up in a rebellion yes but even if
they flare up in Rebellion you're not
allowed to judge them because the other
one must still stay maybe just Trot on a
corn
all right so now we've seen what the
holy spirit is supposed to
do some before the Holy Spirit can be
poured out in a great measure Satan will
make sure that there is a counterfeit
Spirit right mhm and you can be sure
that none of those criteria that we have
discussed will be met by the false
spirit so there will be a counterfeit
spirit before the end not with standing
the widespread declen of faith and piety
they are true followers of Christ in the
churches all the churches out there
including the Roman Catholic Church for
sure including the Pentecostal churches
they are true Seekers of Christ in these
churches and before the final visitation
of God's judgment upon the Earth there
will be amongst the people of the Lord
such a Revival of primitive godliness as
has not been witnessed since Apostolic
times the spirit and power of God will
be poured out upon his children and at
that time many will separate themselves
from those churches in which the love of
this world has supplanted love for God
and His
word both ministers and people will
gladly accept those great truths which
God has caused to be proclaimed at this
time to prepare a people for the Lord's
Second Coming the enemy of souls desires
to hinder this work and before the time
for such a movement shall come he will
endeavor to prevent it by introducing a
counterfeit in those churches which he
can bring under his deceptive power he
will make it appear that God's special
blessing is poured out there will be
manifest what is thought to be a great
religious interest multitudes will exalt
that God is working marvelously for them
when the work is that of another Spirit
under a religious guise Satan will seek
to extend his influence over the
Christian world now one of the things
that the Pentecostal movement is
achieving in the world is unity of the
churches that's true they have a pivotal
role in
ecumenism so Doctrine is being set aside
yeah and the Fe feeling and the
manifestation of the spirit particularly
with regards to speaking in
[Music]
tongues will show that God is on their
side with signs and wonders with signs
and wonders but Doctrine is lightly
regarded yeah and that which God
separated in the
Reformation is being reunited yeah that
tells you there's something wrong with
that
spirit the senses of rational beings
will become so confused that they cannot
be trusted to make right decisions a
bedum of noise shocks the senses
perverts that which if conducted or
right might be a blessing the powers of
satanic agents blend with a dim and
noise to have a carnival and this is
termed the holy spirit's
working we've seen that in videos of the
music being played music the way in
which it is conducted those things which
have been in the past will be in the
future Satan will make music a snare by
the way in which it is conducted let us
give no place to strange exercising
which will really take the Mind away
from the deep moving of the Holy Spirit
God's work is ever characterized by
calmness and
dignity calmness and dignity so that
which has to happen in the heart cannot
be replaced by a manifestation and a
bedum of noise
yeah there will be false speaking in
tongues false excitement
fanaticism false talking in tongues now
we've dealt with all of these issues we
don't have to go into detail it's in the
book of Corinthians that Paul addresses
the false speaking in tongues
right
and he addresses the gifts as well in in
other Epistles like Ephesians for
example he doesn't even mention T but
the the the gift that is mentioned last
is the one that is exalted to the first
position the that's what the church is
doing currently yeah what the church is
doing and if you do not receive this it
is a symbol that the holy spirit is not
working in you yeah so if you have the
manifestation then you have the spirit
but the Same Spirit M occurs in Hinduism
yeah it occurs in
Shamanism it occurred in the ancient
religion Cilan worship for example in
the Roman uh sages they all spoke in
tongues did they have the truth
no and it says they are leading
Protestants and Catholicism to come
together again so this is actually a
uniting spirit but a false one it must
be a false spirit because it is ignoring
the very basis upon which the holy
spirit is to be poured out true and
that's do these churches not say that
the Lord has been done away with yes and
if you've done away with the law haven't
you done away with truth 100% haven't
you done away with the very reason why
Christ had to die on the cross that's it
and the spirit of Truth so then it
cannot be the spirit of Truth it can
only be a spirit yes but not necess not
the spirit of Truth so they have what we
call
here an excitement of feeling but the
influence of such meetings is not
beneficial when the happy flight of
feeling is gone they sink lower than
before the meeting because their
happiness didn't come from the right
Source the most profitable meetings for
Spiritual advancement are those which
are characterized with solity and deep
searching of heart each seeking to know
himself and earnestly and in a deep
humility seeking to learn of
Christ so there is already a false
outpouring of the Holy Spirit and it has
to be
met and we may not become discouraged
the Lord would have cheer every such
worker with the same message that he
gave to the Apostle Paul in Wicked
Corinth Be not Afraid speak hold not thy
peace for I am with thee and no man
shall sit on thee to hurt thee for I
have much people in this city God has
many sincere souls in all of these
churches and we may not become
discouraged we may not become
condemning we may condemn the error yes
and we must keep the balance and with a
spirit of meekness we must show the
error so that is what what we need to do
that's what the Holy Spirit must prepare
his church to do so not
abstain from talking to the people no
not keep your mouth shut reuke with all
because a lot of people now say leave
them where they are no you can't leave
them where they are you can't leave them
in error you have to warn them so the
point we're trying to make here I
think is that the preconditions for the
outpouring of the Holy Spirit must first
be met before we can have a pente costal
experience and
unfortunately before that can happen
there must be a shaking yeah because you
cannot have all the different
opinions in one Accord you cannot have
those that accept the spirit of Prophecy
in one Accord with those who reject it
we cannot have those that accept half
and reject another half in one Accord
with those who accept it all
we cannot have those that honor the law
in one Accord with those that don't we
cannot hold to doctrines of salvation
like the atonement and sit in ecumenical
councils with those that reject it yeah
and even those that accept it who set
aside the doctrines in order for the
sake of unity they are also on the wrong
side of the fence wrong sorry so there
must be a
shaking there was a shaking of the
disciples as well yes after the shaking
the Holy Spirit only could come correct
those that were not part of them from
the beginning they had to
leave so the mighting shaking has
commenced and Will Go On yeah M it's
already commenced that means there are
people that have taken a stand for an
issue and they're living amongst the
people people that have not taken a
stand that doesn't mean that you leave
the people it means you have to wait
till the shaking takes
place and they will be shaken out who
are not willing to take a bold and
unyielding stand for the truth and to
sacrifice for God and His cause the
angel said think ye that any will be
compelled to sacrifice no no it must be
a free will offering it will take all to
buy the field I cried to God to spare
his people some of whom were fainting
and dying then I saw that the judgments
of the almighty were speedily coming and
I begged of the Angel speaking his
language to the people said he all the
Thunders and Lightnings of Mount Si
would not move those who will not be
moved by the Plain truths of the word of
God neither would an angel's message
awake them there's only one thing that
can happen there must be a shaking you
must they must decide to go they don't
want to be part of this movement that
will be ready for the lettering right
Hebrews
12:25 see that you refuse not him that
speaketh for if they escape not to
refuse him that speak spake on Earth
much more shall not we escape if we turn
away from him that speaketh from Heaven
whose voice then shook the Earth but now
he has promised say saying yet once more
I shake not the Earth only but also
heaven and this word yet once more
signifies the removing of those things
that are shaken as of things that are
made that those things which cannot be
shaken May remain so the shaking will be
a shaking out yeah it's a spitting out
shaking out Hebrews 12:28 wherefore we
receive a kingdom which cannot be moved
let us us have Grace whereby we may
serve God acceptably with reverence and
godly fear for God our God is a
consuming fire M God will do the
shaking that's true when laws are made
which make void the law of God people
will have to make a
decision and it's right before the door
yeah it's going to happen and God will
do the shaking
and then we have this final
quote the church may appear as about to
fall but it does not fall it remains
while the sinners in Zion will be sifted
out the cha separated from the precious
wheat this is a terrible ordeal but
nevertheless it must take
place the M I believe that the
outpouring of the holy spirit will not
take place
until the shaking has
come and the shaking will be brought
about by the events prophesied yeah and
one of those is the preaching of the
straight testimony
yes and it is right to play pray for the
outpouring of the Holy
Spirit but a personal
preparation is what God requires now so
that when the events take
place we will be so settled in the truth
that we cannot be moved let's pray
amen Heavenly
Father the world is expecting the
outpouring of the Holy
Spirit we see manest manifestations in
the world but they are not based on
righteousness and Truth to the contrary
they negate the law of God they bring
about unity in false
doctrines and so Lord we wait for the
outpouring of the spirit of
Truth the spirit that will lead to a
greater consecration to the word to
Christ and to his
law and prepare our hearts that we may
be
Christlike to be entitled to be heart of
that loud cry is my prayer in jesus'
name amen amen
[Music]